myriam smir est comptable professionnel
agréé fiscaliste fondatrice de finale
source est avec nous bonsoir lancement
mais cette union alors madame thérèse
quelles sont les erreurs fréquentes avec
l'apc où le pcr eu effectivement comme
on a vu dans le reportage on avait
plusieurs erreurs qui ont été reportés
par plusieurs contribuables souvent les
gens ont voulu être bienveillance prende
avance faire des remises de ce qu'on
appelle des acomptes provisionnels donc
payer d'avancé en fait en prévision des
impôts à la fin de l'année et souvent
ces montants lots ont été attribués ou
ont été utilisés pour rembourser les
montants qu'on avait reçu de pcu ou de
pc heureux donc ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à la basse assurés de voir quels
sont les montants qu'on a réellement
reçu avait tant l'intention de
rembourser les moteurs de pc soit parce
qu'ils ont été rappelés au travail c'est
des situations qui sont arrivés ou
encore est-ce que c'est des vrais
acompte et à ce moment-là s'assurer que
c'est vraiment ça qui est reportée dans
les déclarations d'impôts c'est ce qui
va y avoir une discordance entre ce
qu'on produit et les feuillet qu'on a
reçu mais il ya des corrections et
revenu canada est au courant de ça et au
fur à mesure qu'on va faire les
productions on va pouvoir appeler et
rectifier le tir et pris de passion un
peu à des fois oui tout à fait la
patience va être de mise pour les
prochaines semaines vous avez tout à
fait raison
les travailleurs autonomes ont eu droit
est ce qu'on appelle le phare le
programme phare qui est leur fond des
dés de relance régional
que doivent-ils déclaré dans leur
déclaration de revenus des éleveurs en
fait autant pour le faire que pour
toutes les subventions qui seront des
prêts pardonnable qui ont été octroyés
par le gouvernement fédéral tout le long
de
la pandémie qui continue ya vu une
portion qui était pardonnable ci ont
remboursé le montant le 31 décembre 2022
et souvent l'impression des gens c'est
que il y aura un pardon donc un revenu
reconnu au moment où on va rembourser
mais en réalité ce que la loi vient dire
c'est que le montant qui pardonne et est
imposable au moment de l'octroi donc
toutes les sommes qu'on a reçu que ce
soit pour la cu aussi le 40000
maintenant 60 milles au niveau des avec
la banque ou en cas avec le phare si on
a reçu le montant avant le 31 décembre
il faut alors reconnaître le 25 pour
cent de ce prélat immédiatement comme
revenu dans nos déclarations d'une payer
d'impôts dechy tout à fait pédaler même
si on n'a pas encore le pardon oui mais
on pourrait avoir le pardon donc de ne
pas avoir à rembourser le 25 % capitale
tout à fait et à ce moment là on a monté
vraiment inférieur à rembourser est-ce
qu'on récupère les pots à ce moment là
si jamais au 31 décembre 2022
on se retrouve dans une situation où on
rembourse la totalité parce qu'on n'est
pas en mesure de rembourser le montant
de 75 % à ce moment là oui à une
déduction qui va s'appliquer
ok les étudiants parlons des étudiants
qui avait de petits emplois avec de
faibles revenus qui ne paierait pas
d'impôts généralement ils peuvent avoir
des surprises avec les revenus de la pcu
n'est ce pas oui tout à fait et puis
souvent les étudiants nous disent on va
pas produire une déclaration d'impôts on
a en mode du crédit de base on tente on
en parle et 13000 229 dollars mais ce
qui arrive cette année c'est que soit
parce qu'on a eu la paix s'est vu donc
on a déjà si on a été admis si vous
montrez maximum 14 mille dollars de
revenus et qu'on a eu par ailleurs un
autre emploi temps partiel
là les montants s'accumulent et non
seulement les montants s'accumulent en
ré d'avoir un revenu supérieur mais il
risque d'y avoir aussi une surprise pour
les parents si on est habitué à avoir
des crédits de frais scolarité qui sont
transférées de la part des enfants
ces crédits là ne seront plus transférés
aux parents et à ce moment là l'impact
se fait sentir sur les étudiants mais
également sur les parents cli
si jamais c'est des étudiants qui
habitent plus souvent qu'autrement avec
leurs parents pour faire des revenus
durant la pandémie à plusieurs personnes
qui se sont tournés vers l'économie de
partage
ils ont travaillé avec des entreprises
comme hubert hubert hériteau sydor dash
ce type de déchets pour faire de la
livraison la de repas il travaille pas
pour l'entreprise ans c'est des
travailleurs autonomes dans ce cas-ci
quels revenus doivent-ils déclaré comme
revenu puis je pense au pourvoir
notamment
oui tout à fait donc l'ensemble des
sommes des commissions qu'on pourrait
appeler ou des pourboires également
qu'on reçoit suite à de telles
livraisons se retrouva est incluse dans
notre revenu comme avait dit c'est des
travailleurs autonomes donc c'est
vraiment considérée comme un revenu
d'entreprise donc la totalité des
revenus doit être incluse dans les
revenus de ces jeunes-là faut également
faire attention à tout ce qui est
composantes tps tvq
souvent ça va s'appliquer donc il faut
vraiment s'assurer d'avoir les bons
rapports avec les bonnes définissant des
caisses qui y étaient ps qui est revenue
et pourboires et par la suite ils
pourront être en mesure de réduire aussi
leurs revenus de certaines dépenses que
sony ces caisses qui peuvent déduire de
leur revenu je pense auto et sens
exactement ce qu'ils sont exactement qui
sont rattachés souvent à l'automobile
donc l'utilisation de l'automobile est
l'erreur qu'on fait souvent c'est de
dire je vais prendre à partir du moment
que j'ai utilisé ma voiture mais il faut
se rappeler que la façon de déduire les
dépenses d'automobiles est basée sur un
pourcentage du kilométrage et le
pourcentage du kilométrage veut donc
dire qu'on prend du 1er janvier au 31
décembre
l'ensemble des coûts que a coûté la
voiture se soit l'essence et son
entretien le frais de location de la
voiture où les intérêts payés sur les
prêts si c'est un prêt qu on a eu pour
l'achat de vie du véhicule de
l'amortissement ce moment-là et
l'ensemble de ces dépenses là on doit
appliquer le pourcentage de kilométrage
qui a permis de faire ses livraisons aux
loges je travaille là par rapport au
kilométrage total de l'ensemble de
l'année pour calculer son affaire de
toute évidence a fait il faut avoir à
log book qu'on appelle pour vraiment
savoir les kilométrages exact je vais
aller piger dans ma boîte à questions
parce qu'on en a quand même une tonne de
questions puis je vous en pause quelques
jeunes une question anonyme mais les
bonnes donc je vous la pose à part
l'impôt question les cotisations qui
seront retenus sur la pcu
en fait il ya aucune retenue qui a été
effectué sur la paix civile le montant
de pcu a été de 500 $ par semaine qui a
été payé à l'ensemble des gens qui
étaient admissibles selon certains
critères et donc ce qu'il faut se
rappeler c'est que qu'on va payer le
combat fin de déclarations d'impôts le
seul élément qu'on va payer si l'impôt
fédéral et provincial en fonction des
paliers de revenus qu'on a gagné et
l'ensemble des revenus en fait qui
composent notre revenu imposable
ok je pige da encore une fois dans une
deuxième question dans la boîte création
je suis un retraité de 78 ans qui fait
de la suppléance dans les écoles en mars
2020 lorsque les écoles ont été fermées
j'ai appliqué pour la pcu je lis reçu
qu'un jeu répondent à tous les critères
aujourd'hui je suis allé chez mon
comptable pour faire remplir ma
déclaration de revenus et mon comptable
m'a dit que je n'avais pas droit la pcu
parce que je recevais la pension de la
sécurité de la vieillesse est ce que mon
comptable la raison demande paul émile
riou en fait monsieur rioux il faudrait
savoir pourquoi votre compte à vous avez
dit que vous êtes métier pas admissible
la pension de sécurité vieillesse ou
n'importe quel revenu de penser en
réalité n'entre pas en ligne de compte
dans le calcul du 5000 dollars de
revenus qu'on devait gagner pour avant
droit là tissu par contre une personne
que monsieur rioux qui aurait eu des
revenus d'emploi et non des revenus de
voir ça des revenus d'emploi par
ailleurs de plus que 5000 $ et qui
respecte toutes les autres critères
seraient à ce moment-là admissibles la
pcu dont il faudrait que je sacrifie la
situation pour monsieur et madame mirage
vous est d'une limpidité je vous
remercie d'avoir été avec nous avec
plaisir bonne soirée pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit